so i'm like hold on a second and so you
know she was like talking to me crying
about this and i tried my best not to
laugh i was like you got cheated on by a
not even a human being
that's not a tv show bro that's what i'm
saying so he was cheating on her through
the game
wow through the wow game was somebody
that he didn't even know or verified was
a [__] woman did they ever find out
huh i guarantee you it wasn't a girl
though you know why it was alex
it was alex and you know why it's
because he would have been happy ever
since
so after she found out in five
four three two one como estas everybody
uh we're gonna start off this uh episode
of the genius brain podcast
with the freestyle rap nick go
uh okay okay
okay okay
and go i'm waiting for the beat drop oh
it's already dropped
this one
yeah all right so that was my wrap up
today david
we cannot start this podcast unless you
start start off with the freestyle
that's how it goes
all right bring back
okay
all right um check check okay yup
higher on the snare higher in the snare
please
he hates you alex
ten minutes in but go ahead
okay nick hurry the [__] up uh
and go
nick if you don't say [__] something
i swear to [__] god my name is nick
and i'm here to say
i like i like he's like my name is
[Music]
195 i ain't doing that 195 and he ain't
doing that yeah we eating
and we eating good this pizza with that
pepperoni man that just smells so good
i just want it i need it i need that
cheese i'm finished [__]
everywhere cause i'm lactose intolerant
and i
the first time somebody ever made a word
on this but he said lactose intolerant
and then you got to look at the camera
lactose intolerant and then lac
toaster and don't ever look at don't
look at off the camera
live god live god baby my bed said like
on apple on spotify toaster baby my
man's in the field
you had him beatbox for three [__]
minutes and do my next like right here
is kind of like sore
well alex is he made him [__] do a
beat drop he did so many variations well
you did he said once he said he wanted
to like kind of work on his his his
beatboxing look you don't need to work
on nothing that was perfect you didn't
[__] give him
anything well i tried well i did my
heart too i'm just not very musical
hey that was your heart drop a slower
beat for him maybe that was a little too
fast
[Music]
[__] i'm trying to suck somebody up now
okay i got a boy named nick
his last name is done surprisingly
it rhymes with dumb he dumb as [__] and
he
ugly too surprisingly
he has a boo cause i thought he was gay
cause he likes men so just tip he lives
inside of a den in the forest
and he be eating berries
he getting kind of scary when he getting
mad
now i think he kind of said he like boys
but kind of small so they are led
a little tad tiny he's crystalia
hey that was fire bro let me tell you
something
your boy got bars and then he's about to
drop this
bro david had an out-of-body experience
while he was freestyling that was dope i
literally pictured you in a den with
chris dalia [__]
yeah me too oh yeah she got those
freestyles where you're like damn this
[__] kind of
going when you're going no when i when i
was when we were younger you know i
don't
know when we were younger we used to do
this [__] whack [__]
where i remember we used to like [__]
uh freestyle battle each other on aim
and [__]
because it would give us time to think
and that's how we used to work on our
bars
don't work because this [__]
made me play the stupidest game bro
what game so i went to his house and
they had this little game where
everybody signs in on their phone
and that's the rap battle i'm like
back up bro let me answer this
[__] because i'm about to
[__] everybody up and every time you
type something it'd be like
wouldn't say it like how i'm thinking
and then it would like cut off words and
[__] i'm like
this is the stupidest [__] [__] bro
what is this game it's called the jack
box
party pack and there's all these little
different mini games and there's one
where
you uh you get it's like a four bar rap
battle that you get to have with your
homies
and um it'll like pro it will create
it's like it's like mad libs ad lips mad
libs something like that yeah
rips yeah they'll give you the first
sentence and then you have to rhyme with
that and you can write whatever you want
but you have to keep it under you know
like three sentences bro when you
lyrically unlike this dude
who's trying to write a paragraph and
then what happens i'm thinking like the
and then it's like you will go to the
park and i will
go to the start and you i might bro the
[__] is this [__] if it's too long
like alex's was
then it'll cut off because they make
robots say it and it has to like kind of
fit
because it's like it's a game you can't
just like say whatever the [__] you want
unlike this guy you know
but it's a fun game it's a jack box
party game we should all play it one day
you did not sell me on [__] that is the
worst [__]
i'm not though i'm not all right alex
drop that slow beat again all right you
got to do it here we go
and the topic is the first time you had
sex
okay
okay okay
[Music]
if you don't say it i'm thinking
okay fire
dude
oh man i'm like
hold on
all right man that was my wrap thank you
for my time guys i appreciate it
and i gave you the easiest topic the
first time you had sex if i
haven't had sex yet dude if i give you
how am i supposed to rap about something
i've never done
if i give you a hundred dollars
imagination and i write out a wrap for
you will you let me record you wrap it
oh man that shouldn't be so funny
give me a hundred dollars let me tell
you something the intro to that song is
gonna be pure silence
you don't you don't wanna hear me sing
you don't wanna hear me
rap dude i don't have any i have no
musical experience i'm sorry
i'll do a talk show at the end of the
year all right
your weight loss challenge and i'll do a
talent show i'll say like i said i'll
write it
and i'll tell you i'll record it for you
and be like i'll say it like this like
this like this
i want it to be like your uh your eighth
grade rap your your seventh grade rap
fifth grade sixth grade my bad actually
right if you're gonna bring it up
[__]
can you get it right i think sixth grade
rap here we go
i think i can put my black shoes on with
the all white shirt hey
people look at me like i look like dirt
don't forget them full nah i ain't no
fool yeah i ride on them 20 phones on my
way to school
no one ain't black but i ain't white ash
no i get a lot of stuff
like i lost my toe yeah i got a lot of
friends and i got a lot of money and i
don't like sugar but i like
honey honey yeah i'm in sixth grade and
i'm not that smart now my favorite kind
of food is a
popcorn four foot eight so i'm not that
tall so yeah
in that bathroom i pee in the star y'all
know how to sing
them abcs i'm like testing them and
talent so i don't eat cheese
now imma end this song right about now
i'm gonna
i don't want to end so i'm gonna end it
with a bow how y'all
this guy's he's the rapper bro he's he's
really good he [__] did a rap song
for your guys [__] oh yeah
baby i'll check that oh yeah dude that
song is really good yeah
he made us alex made a rap song about uh
shout outs to eric griffin for
never coming out and training huh how
about you call that one these fools
would always get me hyped that eric
griffin is going to come out and train
now
he will bro
dude like super funny comic he was on jk
news making us die
laughing and i was like oh he's gonna
come out and train aircraft is a big
dude he's like he's taller than me
i never met him he's for sure talking to
me he's like six maybe six two or some
[__] like that we only heard his voice
over um
xbox yeah so like bobby i know bobby
wants to come train with us
and eric says he's gonna come train with
us we just gotta set it up who's more
likely to come train with us first
eric or bobby bobby bobby i think bobby
is more likely to come out then
low-key maybe because bobby might live
closer to us because i know eric lives
far
remember he told us where he lives i'm
not going to say it but he so he's
addressed right now
uh 1414 south 47th street
south 47th south 47th if you live at
that my bad
going to have [__] coming to you but
you're welcome too because someone might
send you some good [__] you know
but i think i think eric will come
because he's done boxing
he's trying to glove works i don't think
i don't think bobby's boxed
bobby wrestled though i want to rest
right wrestle with bobby i'll wrestle
with bobby do some jiu jitsu
i forget how old bobby is man i can't
believe he's almost 50.
he doesn't look like it he doesn't look
like it he doesn't act like it so
whenever i see him
and uh yeah when his age is brought up
i'm like bobby's like what 38 39 or
something like that
bro we played a war zone game together
and we were talking
and i asked them like hey bobby when's
your birthday right
and he's like what [__] you want to know
i'm just wondering
and then so he told me it's like
september 18th it's like the day before
my birthday right
and then so he tells me he was like i
think it's 18th or 17th one of those two
and uh he tells me that he i was like oh
how old do you turn you turn
48 or 49. he's oh i turned 49 this year
i'm like
damn bro i was like dang you know my dad
turns 50 this year
just reminded him that he's just like
he's just like [__] you i'm like hey
and my mom turns 49 this year bro i'm
like
i have to start calling you papa bob
he's so [__] funny i'm just waiting
for him to drop a standard special
he said he's going to right he always
says he's going to but i i legit think
that he is probably
the best male asian standard comic out
there if you guys seen that guy
like perform live he [__] owns that
stage
rip i honestly i don't think i've ever
seen him live dude just look up see his
[__]
yeah but even just playing games with
him like he's he's [__]
funny bobby is funny he's also like the
most gangster person i've ever in my
life he's the only person i know that
has voluntarily sucked a man's dick and
still
managed to keep his heterosexuality i
think i didn't really like that and he
didn't do it in prison
that's gangster yeah he was his best
friend apparently right exactly
that's bobby lee for you baby he's a
he's a nice guy man he's a real good
both i like i love playing with eric too
it's funny because eric
like it's so weird when you go to these
chats and i'm sure you probably get it
like in your youtube thing like how
[__] toxic
dude people talk so much [__] yeah of
course it's so
funny that because it's they're always
there yeah bro so it's funny because
eric's so funny so you just hear him
talk [__] to these people yeah and he's
like shut the [__] up
stupid [__] you [__] suck at this
game it's the funny thing
i love [__] playing with him and so i
feel like you have to do that [__] huh
cause some people get wild
yeah somebody said i don't know stupid
[__] somebody said i have a michael
jackson nose
i don't even know what that means that's
not a michael you they lie
you look like you look like one of those
statues on easter island dude okay
who's whose nose would you say i have a
celebrity it's like a half squidward
oh [__] damn damn squidward it's like
though that's amazing it's a minion
no a pretty big celebrity who doesn't
know who the [__] squidward is that's
true he put you up there
but so you i appreciate you bro hey hey
thanks for always putting me on games
yeah you already know hey that was crazy
though about that whole twitch thing i
don't think
man i had this huge conversation so i
brought mario onto this podcast and we
were talking about
uh this girl named uh hannah from the
show terrace house it's like this
reality tv show
uh when we put that podcast out
information didn't come out that um
her mom is actually suing the reality tv
show so basically this girl
um committed uh she she passed away by
taking her own life
and um girl yeah so on on the show
basically on the reality tv show she
kind of had this moment where she blew
up at one of the cast members and she
like super disrespected him
well in asia cyber bullying is huge like
that's like that's like asian people
[__] like
we could get a degree in that [__] and
it would be like a master's
in divinity or some [__] like what would
you rank your cyber building ability oh
very low
very bro when i see that gray screen
come on with that white outline
and it says david's so co on it i'm like
oh this is about to taste
good
because most people that cyberbully
probably wouldn't put their face behind
it yeah oh for sure i put my face on
yeah i want you to know that i want you
to die
and honestly nobody nobody that's true
nobody uh nobody calls people out like
the way you do
it it tears away at my soul though
because i get really exhausted doing
that [__]
especially because i don't write it and
it's just i have to be in the moment to
talk that much [__] yeah it's almost as
if that person's there and i want to say
everything i can in front of you it's
like
i wish you were here right now so i
could say i want david to talk [__] put
him in his car
[Laughter]
ever since he got that new car bro he
just been ripping everyone a new [__]
because he's like ooh this is nice i
could toss some [__] up in this
[__]
he reclines a little bit he's like yo
[__] this [__]
because it's the only place that i could
yell when people don't think it's a
domestic violence case
yeah sure enough yeah so i have to do it
in my car people like what are you doing
in your car i can't do it in my office
or i can't do it in my house because the
thing about the way you [__] on people
is that it's for it's always for a good
reason it's for a good cause
it's for a good cause and you're very
clear and concise and you always have a
great message
after you call someone to stick it a
stinking [__] [__]
yes and it's like jesus man the way
you're able to turn that around is
like that's that's magic right there
dude and i can't replicate it too that's
why
i got one pig if that one takes not good
i can't do the video because it takes
out my spirit i'm tired how many one
tanks did you do where you're like
you know the first videos that i that i
was doing um on in there
like it was just one takes that's why
there was no pauses there was no cuts
and then my last video i did cuts just
because like uh i said
i said so much [__] i didn't i couldn't
really you said something like extra
[__] that's like not really safe no it
was it was safe it just didn't make any
sense
it was just me just [__] just like
when you get mad and you start saying
[__] like bro i'm gonna hit you with an
orange and then you eat a [__] shrimp
it would just be
this guy's mad it was just pure nonsense
i wasn't really on my game but that's
what i started to realize is like i
think when i did the video the
when i was doing the video about the
mask um if i had done that video maybe
a month ago prior it would have been a
lot more concise but this one i had to
kind of think about what i was going to
say that was a great video so that's one
of my favorites
yeah so i you know it is what it is but
just go back there was this girl
recently on twitch she was a canadian
uh twitcher i i'll put i'll put her name
in the
in the video i don't remember her name
right now but she passed away
recently uh she also uh took took her
life just like that girl hannah did it
just to go back to the haunted thing
let's go even further back she passed
away
um she took her own life and information
came out that she did it
uh by gas so she kind of made a gas leak
in her house
and she committed suicide that way but
what i didn't know when i was saying
this thing was that the the internet
kind of took really poor to her because
of how she behaved in a specific
situation on the show
well later on what they found out and um
this is what her mom said and through a
few other text messages is that
the producers on the show were pushing
her to kind of
be that way to be a little disrespectful
but then because of how she was behaving
a lot and they they kind of predicate
this show on being a show that's all
natural
no script no producer interference or
whatever
so which i feel like i'm not in the
showbiz but i feel like is never the
case exactly so this was supposed to be
the reality tv show that's different
so you're actually just seeing how these
people are and so
uh what it turns out is that the
producers were trying to push her to do
that they were telling
kind of like insinuating that some of
the rhetoric was and this is from a
japanese friend of mine and she you know
she kind of translated everything for me
she said that um the mom was saying that
the producers were saying stuff to her
like
oh well i can't believe that guy shrunk
your clothes in the dryer
who cares you just tell them off do
whatever you want just make sure just
hurt his feelings and he was
they were egging her on that way and
they weren't supposed to do that and so
because of that she got a lot of
backlash she's 22 years old she's super
young
she's not very she's not going to be
used to this type of backlash and i've
said this before on the previous podcast
is that
the hard part about young people who
want fame you think that you only get
the positive things that come with this
industry and you don't
just as much as people will love you
there's that many more people that'll
hate you you have to learn how to
balance that out
that's the hard part right i deal with
that [__] all the time i have to balance
it i just do it by making fun of you and
then i go about my day in the night
then i'm pretty fine yeah but you know
with her and there was another girl um
on twitch i'm not sure how big of a
twitcher she is
twitcher is that the term twitchy twitch
twitter twitter
twitter so big of a twitcher she is but
um big enough where people were really
really sad
uh she also took her life and she kind
of wrote this super sad note saying that
it's nobody's fault
and that uh it was actually a very
positive note but she still took her
life
but if you read a lot of the
cyberbullying comments that were
directed towards her
it's pretty crazy dude specifically to
girl streamers
yeah a lot of these guys who are [__]
losers by the way bro
in cells in cells they're attacking
these women for doing what for playing
games and they're like
but they're watching and they like what
i like they watch you the whole time
they're jacking off to them or something
i don't know what the [__] these losers
are doing but
um that's what i would do when i watch
alex's stream of course beating off the
whole time
two seconds real quick shots on my boy
raymie yeah
and so yeah she i guess she she took her
life and then you know the
everybody on twitch and i think online
is starting to realize how
how toxic like cyberbullying can be um
and i understand too cause like when you
read those comments sometimes it's just
like
you have to really decipher is this
person saying it just to say that just
to piss me off or this is an actual
human being because if it is i want to
[__]
[__] this person up yeah but you can't
because you don't know where they are
you don't actually live
you don't know if they're crazy yeah you
absolutely don't
but some of these people too like they
talk [__] and they see you in person
they're your biggest fan dude that's
what everybody says right yeah like it
happens to me all the [__] time all
my fans are just going like if these
person
these people [__] hated me right they
hated me they handed me that much and i
would do these i would do these like
college stand-up shows or whatever right
they know where i'm at
yeah it's publicized pull up say what
you want to say
you're going to [__] me up you're going
to do all this stuff you know where i'm
at if you have a gun don't show up
though yeah yeah yeah
but there was also a youtuber back in
the day who uh was
was killed by a fan i think i had to
meet jesus
yeah she wasn't what was it she was a i
can't even remember her name i feel so
wrong for not remembering her but she
was a really really sweet girl but there
was a guy who was like a super super fan
of hers
i think he killed her you know i'm
thinking i'm thinking i know what you're
talking about it was like some guy that
swore like they were
soul mates soul mates or some [__] yeah
i remember
and like yeah it's almost like that
[__] eminem song
oh yeah it stands stuff it's just yeah
i mean obviously i mean i got like 500
followers so i don't have that [__]
right but
you know but you know what's crazy
though like i've seen a great grimy
grimy green rhyming
it's crazy because like we've been we
started like well i like started
twitching and stuff like that before and
i just slowly kind of hopped on it too
but it's crazy when i watch alex's
streams and because there'll be like a
gang of people in there and it's always
the same people
you know it's always the same people
that that come back and they watch the
streams and
i just never knew that like this was a
thing like i had no idea i didn't know
how it worked
i didn't know there was so many
different like like like niches
in the twitch community and there's so
much that goes on to it and like
everyone knows each other like they just
know each other by their screen name and
stuff like that and
yeah the people come into like the chat
and they
talk to each other so like i have people
like that like
hey what's up bro hey what's up and
they're just having conversations how do
you how do you
record yourself playing the game so
basically what it is is like you have to
have a computer which
my [__] stream is all [__] up right
now i'm so pissed off because i just
spent all this money on this [__] pc
right
but basically what you do is you use a
software called like obs or streamlabs
obs which
records the gameplay and that system
allows you to plug in like a webcam or
camera into your computer
and you can actually display what your
camera's capturing as well too
so my webcam so it shows my face and you
can move that around wherever you want
and then so it puts that together and
that streams that to a site like twitch
or youtube or something like that
so people just like to watch people play
video games and like these people are
loyal man
yeah the biggest thing eric griffin is
the one that did basically
all of it for me all right man i guess
i'll twist dude this guy convinced me to
[__]
with somebody we were twitching today
and some people were like you got to get
out uh david on youtube
i told david this when people just want
to see me curse people out that's
awesome
who doesn't want to so when i first was
and we all used to tell them my age
twitch you know you're you're bobby's
guy
people like you and they know you play
with bobby so you start twitching right
and his twitch is starting to do real
real good right and it's cool
when you see his [__] cause like when
now when he streams he gets like 200
[__] people
it's crazy right but and it's oh it's
cool because it's always the same people
but
like eric's the one that started it off
for it so he did something like
called a raid right so eric's a popular
guy you know he's on the show
workaholics all that type of stuff
so what eric did once is i played with
him and he's real cool
um he knew he found out that i was
streaming
and so he raided me so he had like 200
viewers he brought him all over to my
stream so i went from like 10 viewers to
like 210 viewers now right
and then eric started doing that for it
but it's cool to see like
it's weird it's like a little family now
every time i go on
i know i know who's gonna be in the chat
i know even if they're not going to stay
are they playing the game with you or
they're not they're just watching so
they're just watching they're just
watching people so even if i know
they're not going to stay like
i every time i turn my switch i know
who's coming in to least be like hey
what's up alex or
because of bobby everybody calls me
chongo and like everybody says team
thick now right
but i know every someone people is going
to come in and say what's up chongo or
they're going to put the little emotes
and [__] like that
it's cool but it's like what he said
when i first started doing it
and like eric used to raid me a lot
people would be like is that a genius
brain
podcast poster in your background yeah
and i'd be like oh yeah it is so like
oh wait that's why i recognize you and
nick you guys are on geniusbrain
you should tell uh alex or you should
tell david to do it david do it
the biggest things like the most things
i hear is tell david to do a podcast
and then hey who would win between you
and bart in a fight
should do a charity yeah and then bart
yeah
no no no they do and
hey who would win bart or david hey alex
this was the funny thing i had a whole
conversation like hey you guys should
set up charity fights where like
you want bart box and then gilbert and
david box i'm like bro why does
everybody watch the fight
you want to see me gilbert box just go
on [__] uh gianni's [__]
story and you'll see me just touch his
nose and he crumbles
crumbles like a wafer cookie dude yeah
we bro we all spar together we all fight
we
it's all good bro but everybody wants to
see it yeah but people ask for this full
so everybody in the comments comment
tell david to start a stream i told him
i helped him set it up
david's gonna do it i got an extra i got
an extra streaming thing if you wanna
i'll give it to you i'll think about i
mean i have a gaming pc too but i don't
know
like the whole thing is like i didn't
game either so like quarantine
the one thing that quarantine did for me
obviously everything is like
crazy and it sucks what's going on but
for like me it forced me to take time
off right which is cool for me because
like
from lifting heavy and stuff like that
like my body feels good and my calves
are a little tight but that's because
they're so muscular
you know what i'm saying but uh it
forced me to take time off and
i never play video games like if i did
it was the ufc video game
and then what she sucks at he beat the
[__] out of me and then
i thought i was pretty good this dude
beat the [__] bracelet that's the
only game i ever played was ufc
but then so quarantine happened and
they're all like hey you should uh
download warzone it's free i was like
[__] yeah i gave it
so hard for me man bro me too i just i
never was into it
all these people were like oh yeah i
play call of duty black ops 4 and
spec ops 3. i'm like i know black ops 2
i played it for like three days that's
it like today i was streaming and i did
for
at like an hour and like 15 minutes i
was like i want to do i don't know
you know what it is and i'll just be
honest like the the whole gaming concept
to me it just reminds me of this one
story
there's this dude i knew in college
right and he loved gaming like i'm
talking about he
played uh wow world of warcraft
he played this wow yeah he played
he played wow he played world of
warcraft right and i'm reminded of the
story because
of how much of a [__] loser
so he had a girlfriend at the time right
um
they split up whatever they're happy now
they're married uh he would they went to
a they went to davis
uh you so she was telling me that he was
acting a little sus
like a little weird right that they
would be um
in class together and because they went
to davis they took very similar courses
they i think they were in the same major
as well so they
had uh um the same classes so as as a as
he's sitting next to her
he would be like on his phone texting or
whatever right and then
she would look over and say oh who are
you texting nothing weird about it just
kind of wondering
and then he would be like what are you
doing and he would kind of like snatch
his phone away
number one my guy bad move you already
look suspicious as [__]
so unless you're getting her like a new
car there's no reason for you to be
doing that [__] right
so the guy's acting a little suss right
and so he's gaming a lot more and then
he starts the game
without her being around because usually
he just games and she just kind of walks
into the room
and so um after a while he was being a
little more weird and a little
a little secretive with his gaming which
is very odd usually when you game if
somebody walks in they just kind of walk
in
the game just playing games and so later
on she finds out
that i don't know suppose like flirting
with somebody
during within the wow community right
that he does these raids with right
and they're like they're like flirting
with each other with their characters on
wow
dude like the [__] shrek character
i'm like hold on a second dog you don't
even [__] know if that's a girl
yeah that could be a [__] dude you
don't [__] know that's the ultimate
catfish right there
so i'm like hold on a second and so you
know she was like
talking to me crying about this and i
tried my best not to laugh i was like
you got cheated on by
not even a human being that's not a tv
show bro that's what i'm saying so he
was cheating on her through the game
wow through the wow game with somebody
that he didn't even know or verify
was a [__] woman did they ever find
out huh i guarantee you it wasn't a girl
though
you know why it was alex it was alex and
you know why it's because
she would have been happy ever since so
after she found out she sent me photos
of the girl right who the girl was
but it wasn't a photo of the girl it was
always a group picture
and i'm like she was like sketch and she
was like i don't know who which one it
is though
but i'm like that means that's a [__]
guy it's a catfish situation
so this whole guy catfish and basically
destroyed his relationship over somebody
that was a
wasn't even a real person yeah that's so
he got catfish and she would only send
him group photos of whoever
like this isn't the real person bro are
you [__] dumb i was like how did you
fall in love with the 3d character
on a game you [__] lose hey i can say
this about games bro too because
i've never been into them like wow and
rpgs and [__] that's not my [__]
but it's different like i i downloaded
warzone and i played by myself
for like three days i'm like this [__]
is low-key
boring as [__] it is right it can be but
then
nick's like oh i got it i was like oh
you do he's like gilbert's like oh i
have it
i'm alright cool but when you start
playing together yes it's
way different bro so like when i first
played i'm like this is boring i don't
know how you guys do it
but now that like i we have groups so
like i have groups of people that i play
with now that shit's low-key so [__]
fun
like i play with them gilbert i play
with my friend aaron
i play with west gaming yeah a west
gaming i play with
my friend mark i think all this sounds
fun too but i think like just me
being in indoors is something i don't
like i generally don't like being
indoors anymore like that's why
i do eight mile walks sometimes it's
like honestly like it sounds crazy but
even when you play for like i my
attention span is really short
yeah so i have an hour that's it yeah
when i play with the homies i'll play
like
i don't even play that long i'll play
like all right let's play and i'll be
like all right bro
of these [__] they play like
eight to ten hours i don't know how they
do it they're dedicated as [__]
he doesn't do it that often though no
but i i love it but i think it's because
i think it's because i love it i love it
but it's also he has a community though
like that's a crazy thing like nothing
that much but i do
i understand it but it's cool but my
whole thing is like
i'm also competitive and like something
like war zone yeah it's
so [__] hard to win that's the other
thing that i like too is the competitive
i don't know why it's crazy to say that
you like a competitive aspect of a video
i think if i understood the competitive
aspect i might get more into it but when
i play a game and i lose
i could literally give a [__] less yeah
and and that only makes the other person
mad
no that's that's a lot of the time too
because sometimes i'll be playing
and i'll just be like [__] it who cares
bro yeah like i'll call it in like
especially if i'm like mentally over it
sometimes i'm not even
looking like i'll be on my phone and
there's been times where we're playing
and i [__] it up for everybody from that
time he bought me back and i wasn't even
on my phone
i wasn't i wasn't even playing the game
i bought him back i was being a good
friend
i run into danger wide open by station
right
at the [__] airport if you play call
of duty you know exactly which one i'm
talking about
outside of hangar one and two bro i run
into the middle
to buy this full back and i get [__]
capped
right after i do it and then once you
die like and you after you hit your
gulag
um you go and view other people's screen
i'm on his screen
and it's just showing him fly down he
lands and just gets [__] kept
oh [__] whoa was i playing bro
there's been times where i've been i've
played video games with like
tiffany's cousins and like the homies
and we play and it'll be like late at
night
and i'll fall asleep i'll i'll be
playing with them and i'll fall asleep
and they're like nick are you there
are you there are you there and they'll
just hear me snore in the [__] mic
because i just fall asleep
but it's with your narcolepsy dude you
just don't do that no more bro
it's not me that's not part of me
anymore oh really yeah i think you do
bro ask anybody we talked about this
it's a competitive game
but also that's what changes it to uh
like
sometimes i'm like [__] it right because
there's days where you're not doing good
and like i'll play for like say five six
hours and i'm just like i'm done bro
see now i know see when we we're not
winning when you go back into the dating
game we gotta find you a gamer girl
that's like
hey bro oh yeah so let's see that'd be
kind of lit bro i train
eat food about what like 6 000 calories
a day
and then like you know me and david was
talking about our
calories you know hey play some games
bro that's just live
talk about podcasts talk about mma and
[__] bro come on dog
are you going are you gonna take uh any
of the uh the the advice from our our
boy kozmeezy have you ever
implemented any of it yeah bro what was
the number one takeaway you took
from him what's the number one take what
you took yeah i love that english go
ahead
uh what was that i think like the whole
uh don't always just come in with
complimenting on their looks and [__]
like that you gotta make them and then
like the biggest thing was like when
you're in a relationship
is like the jealousy thing and that type
of stuff it's weird because like
you know i started reading some of the
comments and you know some of the stuff
that he says
not everybody agrees with right um
like i don't know if i agree or disagree
which is kind of nice hearing him speak
and then kind of
looking back on some of the stuff that
happened in my life that seemed very
congruent to what he was talking about
so one of the stuff that i think girls
didn't like was when he said that um
playing games isn't the problem like you
should always play games and that's not
what he
said verbatim right it was more like the
jealousy thing how he said jealousy is a
good thing you have to give them a
reason to be jealous of stuff
i think when he says that um i think how
i interpret it was maybe a little bit
different how they interpret it because
i
interpret it as like you know always
have a reason to have your partner want
you
that's how i saw it exactly you know
that's that's much better said too
yeah versus saying you know keep them
jealous keep them jealous
yeah yeah you know the the wording might
have been a little funky i'll make them
jealous when i'm winning on them war
zones you feel
me and they can't get one duh alex
that's never going to happen
[Laughter]
not a single girl is good i wouldn't say
that dude but i'm not saying
i can't imagine the girl being like that
war zone score hey bro
oh my god you have 18 wins i've seen
these
i've seen memes already too it's like
it's like uh
what when you're dating a guy you find
out he has zero horses
and [__] bro hey bro that [__] i'm
telling you david would like it because
i know david's competitive right
once you understand the game and then
you start playing and you're like yo i'm
getting
capped in like five seconds what the
[__]
and then all it takes is for you to say
do a quad with us right yeah and then we
end up winning and say even if you don't
get any kills just keep saying these
four in terms of me do a quad what is
this
squad means four people like a four-man
team better with a team bro
yeah bro you don't want to do it like
playing by yourself isn't really that
fun
yeah i only do solos
if i'm streaming i'll do solos because
then like people are talking to me like
oh go to the superstore go all that [__]
right
but like if i'm just playing by myself
like like i have to right now because my
stream ain't working that well
like it's only i'm gonna play with the
groups i'm not gonna play with myself
but
you do a quad with somebody this was my
brother michael this [__] i
don't
ever want wars i'm so boring where's
this one boring so i'm in arizona
we can't do too much so i'm like hey
come on let's just do a war zone
so we do some war zones he's like oh
it's a little boring right i come back
he's like let's play cod we do
and then i was like hey let's do a
couple war zones we play two
the second one we end up [__] winning
this bro [__] yes
[__] yeah yeah i'm like see that shit's
cool huh
he's like yeah but it's still so [__]
hard oh my god that's why it's so
addicting bro because once you feel that
like [__] i beat
there's a 150 people in here that i
don't even know around the world
and i just [__] murked all y'all with
my [__] ground next endo clip
[Applause]
walked into my office and she's like who
are you yelling at
it's mostly at alex but sometimes when
she looks at me i'm like oh man
she's going to divorce me at any moment
hey get her to play i bet you she
changes her mind nah bro hey tiff if you
listen to this play a zone with a
[__] stick i don't think i
will ever ever feel that way about games
i don't
think my brother because my brother was
a huge huge gamer like he was a huge
gamer and he
if he he everything
dude
yeah but even he doesn't play games
anymore so it's hard for me to imagine
myself like i try like i try my best
honestly if it ain't for you yeah you
might not like it
but i was i was kind of that way too i'm
like oh video games just aren't my thing
like i'm like i don't want to just sit
at home and play a [__] video game
but i think once you find a game that
you're like actually really into
animal farm it is dude bro was it called
animal cross
[__] i haven't played anything but i've
been playing warzone for what four
months now
in apex legends because it's like battle
royales those shits are i'm like yo
i can see why people like that's that's
how do people make money on this thing
so like twitch right so like if i'm
there someone wants to subscribe to me
you don't have to like you can just
follow somebody right
but if you want to you could subscribe
to me and like
so like i got these little emotes made
right and they're little like little
like emojis kind of things that are
specific in twitch
that are custom so i went and paid
someone to design them so if you
subscribe to me
you unlock all of these emotes so then
you can go on other people's like
they can go into his twitch chat and use
my emotes and then people oh where'd you
get that you know what i'm saying it
kind of just
spreads it there people can also just
donate to you
that you can buy bits like there's these
bits and [__] that are worth money
and you can just give them to streamers
and then plus people just have like
[__] uh
sponsors and stuff but how much does
this call of call of booty was it called
duty cost free war zone is free oh it's
free it's like
there's like the actual full game where
you get a story multiplayer yeah
and all this other bonus content and
there's one that's like
free the one that everybody's playing is
free it's called warzone
they make their money because they
release like skins and [__] for like
characters and guns that's what bro
i know bobby told us like he's dropped
over like 800 bucks on [__] bro
i've honestly loved [__] but he does
that with
150 bucks on just skins and [__] bro
what is wrong with you yeah dude bro
quick out of your house first
hey [__] bro i feel like i spent like 30
bucks maybe no this floor spent more
than 30 bucks
30 30 that's it i'm gonna spend more
time you have purple tracers bro
that [__] by itself was ten and i bought
that was yeah
okay then where did the other 20 come
from let me see you bought some skins so
no minimum that's 10.
no well oh you bought the the white
m4 didn't you i didn't buy any of that
no dude he spent more than three the
purple thing is the only thing i bought
i understand why people can spend money
though because i play this uh dumb game
on my phone
and in order for me to do better what's
the name of the game uh it's called
seven deadly sins
grand cross so what the [__] kind of
game is that
rpg so i was playing it and then i was
like listen i need to upgrade this
character but it's going to take me
about
two days if i don't spend money yeah and
then i said
27 dollars i should do it
it was worth it yes and i did that for
five characters hey
that's more than me so i understand
hey but he got davis so money i know hey
the only reason why it's so high from
like 150
is because so i started streaming and
then i actually made a lot of it's for
[__] gilbert because he would [__]
give all these subs to people right but
i was like at a hundred people plays
games too yeah
he's actually really good he's really
good of course he would be good i was
like at 130 bucks right and then the new
season four
came out for a warzone and it's like 80
bucks to unlock everything
so i'm like can i say something real
quick yeah it's 80 something like
everything
but if you play the game you get it for
free no no you start to buy battle pass
and then over time you can unlock it
which you still haven't right
it's been like four months oh i got i
got everything no i got it because he's
not that good
so it's like basically it's like he's
like still level
10. all the stuff that you did
gaming without without paying for but
anyway so this is my thought process i'm
like all right all these people giving
me this money they probably want to see
all the new [__] right
back season four this is why you're
still 250 [__] pounds bro
it's because you were there i gotta eat
it
like all this time that you could have
spent just [__]
walk you were playing eight hours of
games hey why walk when my character run
about four miles each wardrobe
how many did your character run bro yeah
bro
do you have double time on yours yup
what does that mean exactly what time
means you
don't even know what double time is bro
this guy is a [__] narc dude he
doesn't know anything about working oh
you're a piece of [__] what the [__]
are you talking about right now hey but
i put the money from the people back
into the game
so i was like the first day i feel like
hey guys look all the money i i said
this on the switch i'm like every all
the money you guys gave me i put it in
now you guys get to see all the guns so
people are like oh can i see this
blueprint
i was showing them i'm like cool this is
their money i just put it right back
into it
you act like you're [__]
[Laughter]
this is [__] insane there's so much
information out of nowhere too this guy
he was literally not into gaming at all
when you find a game you like bro like
like i was trying to say
i understand why these kids get addicted
to it now
because it because it can't extend the
addiction towards gaming just because
it's very gratuitous and it's very
instant
you know the thing about alex though is
like when this dude likes something
he [__] really likes it dude i saw
this guy eat 14 papooses in front of my
face once hey that's [__] he loves
his boy bro the last time i saw an
animal eat that much was when a [__]
lion hunted a hyena
like this [__] he nick bought a
bunch of papoosas and i was like oh
that's dope
he bought a [__] ton i ate two i was
like i'm stuffed he goes two i just had
six
i was like six he's like y'all gonna eat
your papooses and i'm like bro
two more right when i got home [__] bro
dude that [__] is just like
masa cheese and a bunch of vegetables
it's very hard
masa's corn oh okay is that oh that's
like what the tortilla is made out of
oh okay see i don't even know what it
made out of it just bomb it full
bro hey give me any food bro i'll eat it
a hundred percent are you a salvia you
don't know what my sis bro
bro i don't know i'm not i don't
i don't know man i think you need to
[__] work on the stuff that cosmo
gave you
and then we got to send you out to a bar
to pick up random women
i don't think alex is going to do that
[__] i'm not yeah i don't think he's i
don't think you're about that life
it's interesting though just like like
watching
like observing how people feel about the
advice that he's giving right some
people really [__] with it
other people don't believe it i think i
think when it comes to his stuff and
social anxiety
it works for a certain type of dude yeah
that has no social skills
and it also works for a certain type of
a woman that it'll work on
i don't think like maybe his advice i'm
just speculating is like it probably
won't work on every woman
obviously but that's not the point um
but it does help guys go out there and
start to
break down their social anxiety because
you know there's a couple of home girls
that watch that video and they're just
like
that [__] would [__] never work
like for example like i know a couple of
homegirls like if you ever walked up to
them and said
you have good energy they would
literally give you the [__] finger
and tell you
that's that's what that's what you're
supposed to go say to chicks like when
you go up to them
yeah don't don't say how you feel
about what they look yeah say you have
good energy i just want to let you know
that
i know a couple of home girls and i'm
saying this like legit
i've seen a couple of dudes use this
approach on them and they literally told
them to go [__] die
so so but he never said it's gonna work
all the time yeah yeah
but that's another one what's another
like hot hot fire one
i've heard the no energy one that's what
he said and then he also mentioned the
the topics about um never compliment a
girl on how they look
yeah um because it because it doesn't
work however i've seen it work quite a
few times i think that also depends on
what the guy looks like though yeah so
the guy is
a very attractive dude like brad pitt
you know you could say [__] anything
yeah if the dude look like liv god i
mean you could say yeah they do look
like alice right and he comes in
and he's just like hey man baby girl
that must be looking tight
i'm my hey girl my you know war zone
155 that's what i'm gonna say level one
she's like she's
[Music]
yeah but i've seen like dudes to use
that but obviously they look very good
so they know what they're worth
right so they come through and it's just
going hey baby [__]
so i remember that show that that dude
cosmo was on i remember
and they would like i remember one of
the things that
i would watch them do a strategy was
like negging
what's that where like they'll say
something like mean to the girl that
they're trying to say
that they're trying to talk to and hopes
that they'll be like
want to talk to you more pretty much
it's like hard to get
but that's the only thing that i
remember and i remember like all like
the pickup line because i remember that
was really big at one point in time oh
like pick up our stuff yeah like that
was like that was all over like
it was like vh1 it was on that was the
show that he was on he wanted yeah and i
remember like
one of the things they were talking
about was nagging so you should try that
just go to a girl and be like really
mean to her
[__] bro oh you should just walk up be
like your [__] smells like fish
i'd be like hey you got zero wins on war
zone huh
no she'll be like does somebody [__]
lose a little brother how the [__] did
he get into this bar
i'm like hey what's your kd that's what
i thought you ain't me
trash what is kd kill death uh like your
killing ratio like how much time you
kill somebody and
um
boy gets obsessed with something or he's
like into something he's
into it [__] gamers and they're
[__] acronyms for all this [__] hey
man
when you come through make sure you get
your abcd uh ft hyphen six seven five
seven hey what are some uh like uh what
are some codes that you would say in
warzone that like you don't think you
would know and then
well you'll say it and then try to make
him guess okay let's see what those
codes are
um like what what
what do you think a uav is oh that's
easy dude
easy dude those are tough levels easy
universal ass vagina
universal apps hey go get you go get a
res
rez easy [__] dude go get me a [__]
resurrection get jesus christ on this
because he never dies
okay hey they have big blue
oh big blue that's right that somebody
was drowning so they just suffocated so
that might they turn baby blue hey
hey uh uh
that's because the [__] taco man died
yesterday when i [__]
right
hey y'all want to bust the scavie scabby
easy let's make sure that happens dude
that's what we go out and we just start
shooting people in kneecaps only for a
six year bro hey turned out way better
than i thought
you know what i'm saying you don't [__]
with me when i get into something i'll
get into something dude
i think you're ready to play this
[__] game bro oh i think so i think
i'm fine
it'd be so fun to get david to play with
us just for like
yeah me you you know i could never play
a game in front of mario
she hates games yeah she detests them
yeah so i have to do it here in this
office
perfect do it bro because you've got
some good ac up in this [__] so why not
wi-fi is good i'm just going to turn
this room into a pc
like it's going to be four desks here
with all then we're just going to play
all day but
what's so shocking is like the money in
it right yeah so like when i when we did
twitch
i literally did it because on xbox you
can screen record like your game
and i was like oh this is cool like i
want a screen recorder but it didn't
hear everybody's audio
so there him and gilbert like oh do
twitch because then you can hear
everybody's audio
so that's why i started doing it but
then so i started looking more into
twitch bro you watched some of these
streamers
100 donation 100 donation 10 if 10 50
gifted subscribers 25 if i was a
twitcher with twitter
would you guys would you guys donate
money to me that's so odd
like i find that a very odd thing it is
a weird thing but
like i wouldn't appreciate it no of
course but one of our homies like raymie
that we play with
there's just one guy that just gives
them [__] money bro good amount of
money dude
are they having sex no they've never met
this they're having a personal
relationship but
[__] georgia bro about yummy people 700
people on this town
and so he's trying to move out here that
that's who we've been talking with like
gilbert stuff me and him are gonna try
and get a spot
right and we're gonna go towards that so
like even on twitch he has this little
bar at the bottom it says
uh try to move to california for my
dream right because he
i think he's going to help him out over
at tiger belly doing some like assistant
work or something
like editing stuff so but like his goal
was 2
000 bro and it's been up there for like
three weeks now he's already had eleven
hundred
i've just donated money yeah just to
help him move out just to help him move
out here
so that full i told him like you might
be able to move out here and just live
by yourself right away bro he's he's
making
his shit's blowing up but it's crazy to
see because people are just
donating money i wish i see that makes
me want
i i understand why people can do this
for a living because if you're
if you're enjoying what you're doing on
a daily basis it's cakewalk
yeah i mean i mean yeah it probably gets
exhausting to stream eight to ten hours
a day yeah that probably it is [__]
exhausting
but if you enjoy what you're doing then
why the [__] not yeah you know and it's
fun i like it
because i get to play with my friends
and it's fun and if like honestly if you
lose there's nothing like there's no bad
consequences too i want to box
like vasily lobochenko all right and i
don't know if this gaming stuff is going
to help me bro it will help your hand
eye coordination oh he always says that
and he's always [__] dead ass bro
like he's so serious about it i'm
telling you bro what because i'm a
trainer at heart right so i see this
stuff and just
having to work your reactions on some of
these you sound like you're selling
snake oil to me right now dude
bro david listen to me puppy poppy poppy
oh [__]
he's about to sell you hey bobby bubby
do it
i can't do when i first started playing
[__] kd like
.46 bro [__] right there's been times
now
where i've killed people in this game i
[__] slaughter them and murder them
right and i don't even know how i did it
i'll be running down
[__] uh well that's what i see when
you guys play these games
and then all of a sudden you're like
kale kale
and i'm like who did you kill i didn't
see anybody die that's not how you start
though bro i'm telling you
what when we walked through boneyard
right it's a bunch of these broken up
places it's so crazy how you're using
all these terms and david has no idea
what the but there's people hiding in
these planes
i did this kill i did two kills two days
ago i was playing with my friends
i'm running and i don't know how i saw
it but i'm like oh someone immediately
just turned to the side murder them and
went straight and right after i did i'm
like
i don't i don't even know that's what i
see i don't get it and you guys keep
saying these weird
terms saying i'm over here my clash
that's like the thing bro if you get a
team like bro you you
that just boosts up your ego bro you're
like man i just slaughtered a whole i've
never seen so much
joy i've never seen so much joy in
somebody's face right now man you really
do enjoy gaming
it's fun bro you found your calling man
fun bro
[__] everything else dude just game for
the rest you got good really fast too
yeah because i like it so it's like you
know i'm a [__] fighter i'm the champ
i'm the greatest fighter alive right
i'm [__] best cod player alive bro
let them know bro let the people
understand
in a world in a world of god how good
are you in a world scale
not that good honestly okay you watch
some of these people
game it you're like they're playing a
lot [__]
and it's also crazy to see how like i
remember
growing up playing video games like as a
kid i'd always feel like
a loser playing it you know i mean like
like this isn't gonna playing video
games is only gonna get you
good at playing video games right but
now when you see that there's a whole
[__] market
with it like the fact that they put
video game
clips of like pro or semi-pro players
and they put it on espn
and they put it on sportscenter and abc
is
showing the like the video games of like
like the video game leagues and stuff
like that
it's crazy to see how much it's blown up
and
and honestly like there's this game
called overwatch
i've never played it i'm not really a
big fan of it but i remember we were
we're eating at a restaurant and they
were playing on abc like a whole
like uh like the whole like a arena and
everybody playing
and it's like the production value is
really dope like
they make it to the point where you
don't know what the [__] you're watching
at all because it's very abstract that
the characters are crazy
and the guns are crazy but you watch
them play and it's
it's crazy how fascinating it is and how
you actually start to watch it
and get into it so perfect example
overwatch
that exact video game right so i'm
chilling with my friend alfonso
he's like hey you want to go to this uh
event my father didn't even sound like a
real person to be here
[Laughter]
that boy get down on the barbecue though
[__] i know you've seen them pictures on
the ground
you just want to learn some numbers
but straight up so we're chilling and
he's like hey
me and our homie ken we're gonna go to
uh some event
for blizzard he's like you wanna come
it's only like 20 bucks and at the time
i'm like
sure cool i'll go i don't have nothing
to do i didn't know what blizzard was or
anything like that
so we're going i'm like so what is it
he's like oh it's an overwatch game
i was like oh i was like oh video game
he's like yeah we're just going to go
and watch because they're in they were
into overwatch and then he's telling me
he's like yeah people take it serious
it's like a sport i'm like oh no they
can't do that [__] right
like that's not that serious so we go to
the blizzard thing it's like in burbank
or glendale or something like that the
studios
we go in the first thing they give us is
these you know those inflatable sticks
where you can hit together
they give us those and what the [__] are
these for he's like you'll see when you
get inside bro
so you first you walk in merch
everywhere people buying so much merch
team jerseys for these teams because
there's like squads and teams right
insane
i'm like what the [__] bro like lines
people buying jerseys
like 80 bucks and [__] right so we get
in it's all state it's almost like a
stadium
you sit it's like a half stadium you sit
in your your seat and
the kids come out on each side they sit
at their computers and
the match starts and they're just
playing the game people are screaming
when someone gets a kill screaming
[__] hitting it there was this one
girl like one of the team was like an
eagle or something like that she kept
going
like standing up i'm like you started
doing it too i'm like yo i'm like yo
they're taking this [__] bro i'm like
[__] this kind of little
dude i was like this world has changed
so it's insane they have commentators
bro
yeah and the commentators do a really
good job of making you feel like you're
you're like you're playing too you know
when you watch ufc and you see the
camera come down
at the desk same exact [__] at that
because my brother watches this stuff
right and i look at it and i'm like this
is the most unentertaining thing i've
ever
exactly yeah but when you sometimes when
you actually like if you were to sit
down and actually really watch it
i guarantee there's gonna be some value
of like man there's actually like
a way better you gotta like the game uh
that's what i realized because i was
like you when i
even when i was there i was like it's
because of what i place value in right
so it's
it's when i see somebody who does well
in the game it has zero value in my life
right so versus when i see somebody
physically hurt somebody or attack
somebody i'm looking
at that physical and what it took to get
there right so there's a lot of factors
in that
when i see somebody do it in a game i'm
just like all right that's cool and it's
also it's like you don't have
like once if you were to play the game
and then you were to watch it then you'd
be like then you'd have
to understand it feeling like yeah but
even then too because i used to play uh
smash brothers a lot right yeah
i was good at smash brothers like i'll
[__] you up i bet you even right now i
still [__] you up with this match for
the turn and i have okay because i
haven't played today
i haven't played in a while but i'm
still probably pretty decent but like
even then like i would watch other
people play it doesn't do anything for
me i know they're way better than me but
it's just more like
cool and it's so funny it's just a video
i was like that too though like
growing up i don't want to watch you
play a game
i want to play myself right and even
twitch i
twitch was never a thing on in my life
until i started doing it
but now all of a sudden i'm catching
myself like an
attic dude because i know because i know
like the excitement it is right when you
win some when you win it right it's hard
so it's cool to watch other people win
and then you see the reaction like oh
[__] yeah we gotta wait
what i'm going to do i'm gonna set up a
camera at your house and then right was
just about to pop off i'm gonna cut off
the internet
it happens like today when i'm in the
middle of a [__] game and my power
goes out bro
he was pissed he was so mad he was like
so mad while we were like playing
earlier
that's because i have i spent all this
money on my computer right
my laptop broke i needed a new computer
anyways we started doing this twitch i'm
like cool i'll just put some
more money get myself a real good
computer right so i do it
and now all of a sudden the [__]
twitch just not working so i was pissed
off the whole time
we're playing a game we're doing pretty
good and all sudden
boom i'm like you are never going to be
able to move out of this house because
you keep spending money on this game
stuff
bruh as long as as long as the gaming
makes money
then you are okay yeah he's getting
there for sure
yeah it's maybe can you guys support my
man's habit
by uh watching his strimes
support him at liftgod.com yeah bro
that's
l i f f f
god g-o-d-d baby dd and those who
were repeating [__] letters man the
last letter people like i can't find the
big mad podcast i was like yeah because
it's [__] spelled stupid
that's cause we just have that idea real
quick we're like a g for each one of us
and it kind of just did it you know what
i'm saying
but eli that was given that name so
that's how i lift god
he is the live god that's how i do it
all questions about lifts you ask about
this guy but see
because of how david thinks of the game
and his
his uh his uh like attitude towards it
like you're not like uh that's whatever
i think that's why you would be so good
on twitch i really think i really think
i think i think that's why you would
probably go like this on twitch
camera on david anywhere people are
gonna watch right
but second i don't think this dude is
ever going to want to play video
but like him and bobby playing a game
together i think would be the funnest
thing
i think you should just do it just for
that the only thing that i probably
would like about gaming is the fact that
i'm just going to say the
most terrible [__] about the person this
guy does the same [__]
this guy talks [__] to [__] everybody
little kids
mostly little kids i would make it a
point to make a kid cry
oh it's fun he's done it yeah
stupid [__] in the game right like at
the end like you can talk [__] to them
like i remember i i've done it with them
in my hey you guys when we talk [__] you
guys want me to
want me talk [__] and i'll [__] go
off on them right give us a little taste
of like what you would say too come on
let's we'll do this i'm the kid all
right yeah so we're playing right hey go
to the bunker but the po
no you gotta you like but you win
because you have a riot shield
okay i have a i have a white shirt you
hate riot shields too so
the person that you're playing you're
playing against them right
and you could hear them no no only only
so i say you kill me
you can hear my reaction for like
whatever the one two seconds that they
let you
okay but you can't hear you uh i can't
hear you
at the very end of war zone say you win
they if you stay at the end whoever is
left like first second third place if
you guys stay to the end
you guys can talk to each other oh like
type no like actually
talk to the head bro you can find my
name my name is
uh peter wonkers from peter wanker
that's your screen name yep peter
wonkers
peter wonkers uh peter wonker's penis
mouth here we go
peter's wonder penis mouth i'm coming
like yeah that's why i thought [__] i
just [__] kept your ass [__]
chunkers
ugh i'd be like yeah [__] well it
depends on what you got right
say you have a right show but again why
you such a [__] they don't have to use
a [__] riot shield
obviously you're not good at the [__]
game and have to use a ride [__] and
hide behind that [__]
i have cancer why would you say this
[__] bro
take off the right shield but i can't
because i'm
so sad and you just yell at me i have
two days to live
okay let's cheer you back up you feeling
better i feel a little bit all right
take out the [__] right should you
piece of [__] guess what i don't have
kids i was trying to make you feel bad
[__] i'm actually an 82 year old man
die bro i don't give a [__] then well
guess what when i die i'ma come back and
haunt you then i'ma [__] your mom after
she died that's fine [__] but you ain't
playing warzone anymore
i'm dead how many [__] wings you guys
honestly at the very end when they were
both yelling each other
is exactly what i was like the first
part where david was waiting for alex to
talk and alex was waiting for david to
talk
that never happens it's just a
[__] of people saying
you're [__] trash you [__] a piece of
[__] that is hilarious there's a lot of
stuff my friend aaron
our friend i was trying to make it as
difficult as possible who says anything
bad about me to care
hey my friend aaron he did the funniest
thing once we played and he always says
like if he kills somebody
oh my god this guy's literal trash
literal trash right and you go
and then we started doing it for
everything so yeah right at the end like
little trash little trash
when people are trying to talk and [__]
it's so [__] a little trash
but no there was one game bro i would
just say ridiculous [__] oh trust me i
got pissed there was one game
i was doing a solo and i hadn't won one
yet right
and i like it comes down to the [__]
wire bro
there's three people left and i'm doing
good i got like nine kills and [__]
right
so the gas is pushing us to the middle
of a yard
the look on david's face right now
trying to get over the start right now
you can't hide behind the rocks or
anything like this
all of a sudden they spawn a [__]
truck right in the middle of it there's
some what's it called big betty
is it big betty yeah big betty so it's a
big ass [__] truck right you gotta
throw like four c4s on this [__] to
blow it up
oh you guys no frame of reference of how
i just pictured a [__] truck
appearing out of nowhere yeah yeah
basically so it appears out of nowhere
right
three people left all of a sudden you
see the truck turn red on the map that
means an enemy got in it
and they start driving around in circles
right in circles
in the middle of the circle and we have
to get pushed into the flat end right
so i'm like i have no more c4s the other
person's already there he's not shooting
him that means he has no c4s
so i jump down and i shoot the other guy
and down him
this full because he has a car no one
has anything else to do he just [__]
runs us over and wins right
so i'm so pissed the [__] off i'm like
such a [__] bro
right so then he go at the end of the
game he goes he's like
oh you [__] suck he starts i'm like
[__]
you're the one that had to use a [__]
car to to kill us what are you talking
about i
suck well yeah i just came back for the
gulag i don't have any guns i'm like
well if you're so good
[__] why don't you [__] kill me with
your pistol since i [__] suck
he's like why don't you get better i'm
like [__] you gotta use a [__] car
to kill me now
that is a problem with me that i'm also
scared about too it's like when i play
this game
i'm for sure gonna say stuff that's
gonna get me canceled because i'm gonna
say i'm gonna say offensive [__] just to
pick everybody off
before every time bobby plays with us
hey you guys streaming we're like yeah
okay okay don't say anything racist
i wouldn't say anything racist but i see
some [__] up [__] don't say anything
stupid
you [__] kill people like you're a
foster child dude shut the [__] up
there's nothing wrong with being a
foster child i would just say things to
make people mad
that's why i can't stream you should no
that's why people would love
i have friends who are in the foster
system and it's not their fault i just
want to put that out there i'm not a
terrible person
so dude this is what we're gonna do
we're gonna we're gonna take a day
or date where david no alex is going to
give david a crass
crash course on how to play warzone and
you're going to be there and i'm just
going to
live stream it i think it'll be great
because watching this fool will go
through this experience it'll be [__]
hilarious
oh i'm going to get cancelled i'm going
to say some of that [__] just
bobby and eric running a trio bro yeah
that'd be
that [__] would be so funny you should
do it you guys need to she's just gonna
be mad at me because i'm gonna be bad at
the game eric would be mad at you but
that's fun though that's the fun part
i'll be like at me it's a [__] game
yeah
eric eric's funny eric gets mad at all
of us all he gets mad at all of us he's
like
why we sh see this is why i think we
should have done this
that's exactly what that was griffin
this is why i said we should have went
over here this is why
because basically what happens is if you
don't do
that he always every time we lose he
always has it's so [__] fun and
sometimes there's games where we're all
play
and everybody just wants to wait in a
room
for 15 to 20 minutes your boy is out dog
i can't i can't do this [__]
if we're gonna play a game i'm not gonna
play a game where i literally
sit in a room and wait and that's
bobby's changed though when bob started
playing no more he liked to camp
bro he literally would be scared like
bobby would be like like
ah let's not go out there let's stay
here let's stay here so we would say in
a house there's this one house in
farmland
that has like an underground thing and
like we would literally run to that
house
and just go hide in the bottom first
point
just to be though he didn't have to get
in gunfights
in a shooting game you don't want to
shoot other people you know what's the
point it's not like you're actually
going to die
but sometimes it's scary though
sometimes it's like you feel like the
heat of the moment hey bro if you have a
good headset on i'm not gonna lie to you
you're running through like a field it's
dead quiet and if you have that [__]
turned up bro i can't tell you how many
times this has happened to me
bro oh my [__] bro
like because that [__] is loud and when
you get shocked
when you get shot you're like oh [__]
right and then all of a sudden your
controller starts shaking his shield
so i forgot to tell you we were playing
we were playing a couple days ago and
gilbert
literally turned the corner someone like
shot him and it we were all like
oh [__] we got super scared bro gilbert
sends us a picture
of his pants ripped because he got so
scared
that he ripped his jeans and he wasn't
wearing underwear by the way and who
wears
who wears jeans like right here too
you're like what's up
this one had a thousand-year-old egg
there you get a chinese
[Laughter]
bro and say it comes down to the wire
right
it's like last 2v2 or last teams
and say you're like the last person
alive and there's like one other person
there's two other people
dude you're adrenaline and your heart is
because like everybody's watching you
think i would ever feel like that man
because i i have to care about losing
hey there's one time bro
i bet you won't dude there was one time
bro that bobby ended up being the last
person right
and we were playing a quad so four four
of us on a team
he was the last person and it was him
versus one other person
so he goes and hides under this bridge
and everybody's talking to him and you
could hear bobby getting stressed okay
okay okay okay and then we're like hey
dude this is shut the [__] up
i was like shut the [__] up and he's
just sitting like
you can just hear how would you get so
stressed over again
it's i don't know it's so different when
you find the game that you like like i
can play apex
the other game i play i don't give a
[__] bro like if i get killed i'm like
all right cool cool but warzone's
different bro i don't know why
this full this was very invested you are
so [__] you actually sound like an
addict
like you sound like like the way you're
talking about there's some games that we
gotta play what time
yeah let's let's get out of here you're
talking about this game as if it's like
a [__] crack rock dude
no wait no one do you like his face the
camera can't really see his face but
this the way this fool is looking at
alex
is like you are hey but for real why i
like it so much
is because like normally me if i'm home
trying to convince me so hard
if i'm home right bro he's really i
convinced david david is going to play
call of duty guys just
i'll let you know i would never think
that david was going to
but if there's ever a time where he is
now's the time it's going to happen is
because alex is here but
here's why and this is just me being
serious right if i'm home
especially during quarantine like i
don't like to be home
like during my normal life i don't like
to be not in the sense of that's just
because
if i'm just home and there's nothing to
do and i'm not talking buddy bro i just
i don't get in a good mind space right i
just i don't
so i don't like to be home so this the
video games and [__] especially because
of quarantine i'm not able to work
if i was just gonna have to stay at home
and i'd do something i probably would
have gone [__] crazy
so this [__] has helped me out a lot
because i'm like oh now i got something
to look forward to and i'm still able to
play with my friends
so now i understand why people like this
[__] right or like say if you
if you grow up and you're not that like
competitive or you can't be in sports
and [__] right
games are another way be like oh look i
can i'm good at this game i can put it
and then you see these people make money
and [__] but
for me i think i i liked it a lot more
because it was like
oh cool like this helped me like have
fun throughout all this [__] why i
didn't just have to stay home and be
like [__] going out of my mind and be
like hey nick can you hold mitch for me
and he's like nah bro
sorry i can't i hate you i [__] hate
you bro and i'm like hey
what's up don't get a text back
and he's like oh [__] four hours later i
just found my phone when it really was
just you know
that [__] happens to be so often come on
david people get hella bad
david
when i first started training david i
thought he was a liar like
he would tell me things where i was like
oh dude you're lying out of your [__]
mouth there was times where
we retrain at 10 o'clock he'll text me
at 10
30 and say hey man i had to i have an
audition my bad
i'm not going to come in today and i'm
like oh yeah bro you couldn't tell me
like
40 minutes ago but david is really that
guy like he's so
spacey sometimes because i think when
david gets and you're in a lot of ways
you're very similar to alex
like when his mind is focused on
something the rest of the world doesn't
exist
at all and he's he has witnessed me lose
by phone so many times
i have so many of david's belongings
like
i'll i'll find like a shirt i'll be like
who's [__] shirt is my shirt
i remember when i first started training
with them too i remember i came
i was walking by david's old hannah
element that [__] was a push or two you
know what i'm saying
and like oh his phone was just in the
[__]
mouth so i go in there i'm like hey
davey you dropped the element right he's
like yeah i'm like your phone is just
literally right in the wide open dog
give me times we've had to
rip apart the gym to find this guy
it's just it bro the amount of times
like people think
i like dodged their callers is because i
literally don't know where my phone is
literally and i always have it on silent
because i'm either shooting something or
i i don't like the sound of a
of a phone ringing i hate it so i have
it on silent all the time which makes it
worse for me to find my phone
so i just have to know where it is yeah
so if anyone's on there like
someone needs to contact david just
don't call him oh by the way i also lost
my credit card for the past like
week bro what is going on and then uh i
knew that nobody stole it
because there was no charges on it so
i'm like oh it's it's somewhere
on me it's somewhere in this house right
so i found it this morning guess where
it was
in your car in my wallet where was your
wallet
it was in my it was on me my wallet was
lost
so i i didn't think i should look at my
wallet that was the last place i looked
was my wallet
yeah the reason why i brought because on
saturday we were going to the same spot
to watch fights
right and i texted him like at 11. i'm
like hey yo you want to carpool
i'll throw you some gas money and i
didn't hear anything back from until
like
5 40. no no no
i just found my phone i was like oh so
yeah i went i went uh swimming at
mariel's parents house right
and uh i couldn't [__] find my phone
until the last minute and so there was a
bunch of people that came in because
they're selling this house and people
came to view it view it
and i and i thought i left my phone so i
thought somebody jacked my phone but
i just left it in the car and the side
in the side pocket
and so and the reason why the phone
couldn't hear any text was because i
left it in the car
it was 97 degrees a day it overheated so
it shut down yeah bro
what the [__] is wrong with you yeah man
that's that's your boy david still i
don't know what's going on in my life
we just had this conversation i've
gotten worse at my phone i used to be so
on top of everything like text message
respond
right away instagram dm respond right
away
speaking of just today my manager got
hella mad at me because i was supposed
to pitch something to comedy central
today
and uh so i got the whole pitch deck or
and i'm supposed to pitch this idea to
them
i i for some reason i'm so spacey i
don't know what i read but i pitched
them something that had nothing to do
with what they sent me
and then he emails me back he goes did
you read the things dude if you don't
want to do it you say you don't want to
do it
i want to [__] do it he goes why did
you send that and i'm like what do you
mean
he was like you sent them a whole story
you were just supposed to pitch them one
paragraph
i was like oh [__] my bad so i was like
i'll just i'll just
shrink down what i wrote into a
paragraph i send it back out he goes no
you dumbass
you said it's not even what they asked
for
you just reset them a shortened version
of what they didn't ask for you have to
rewrite something else
so i wrote them three wrong things so so
what did they say do they respond to
that
no so i don't think i'm gonna get it
like i'll look at my phone and then be
like oh [__] i didn't even know i got
this text message
i was like oh [__] let me respond back
real quick but i used to be so on top of
that
can i say something i have an
observation on alex's like his last
thought
alex is really good at like and as soon
as i i know as soon as i text alex
he'll text me right away immediately
i'll but hey you want to train tomorrow
yes right i tell him wherever we're
going he goes
ever since war zone though never doug
all asses our message is full three
hours later
oh yeah all right all right man this is
the same [__] dude bro
it's it's not even trolling but it was
even no it was even before war zone and
i i was having the conversation with my
friend
uh i was like yeah i don't know what it
what it is like i think
because i used to be so invested in my
phone yeah but i think because i've
gotten busier with like life like
if a client texts me or some [__] like
that i respond right away because my all
right this is work and stuff but
i feel like i've kind of just stopped
caring about other
little [__] now yeah but i've noticed it
like i forget what happened someone had
sent me a text
and then i was like i something i should
have responded to but i just didn't
yeah and then i was just like all right
like i don't know what the [__] happened
to me before war zone
i think we try to stop playing games
dude like the way you first of all we
just did a whole hour podcast
about your addiction right now i can't
believe we talked that long about it the
way you talk about this game is
ridiculous i thought it was gonna be
like a 15 minute the way i talk about
this game is the way i talk about those
shorts you're wearing too
oh yeah brand ambassador alex acosta
targeting princess target too bro you
are fun bro
no but i was just talking about this
with uh uh with my mom i was like
i gotta stop i'm like stop streaming
because i know
like oh i was telling you guys this like
i know life's gonna get back to normal
so i gotta
start not playing as well no more we're
back at one
right which but i know like if it's
something i i'm i can get addictive but
i know how to stop it like i can just be
like all right cool
what was happening with the whole
unemployment situation then because so
they're not extending it as of now so
they're not extending that
600 a month i think california is trying
to do it by itself though
yeah but the problem is is that extra
six hundred dollars is from an act
that's
federally uh funded yeah so a lot of the
republicans
um apparently don't want to uh
if they want to lower the uh what you
call it it should be something though
yeah yeah so they're saying 300 um an
extra a week
that's still extra but the same time
it's like dude that like
it's not like uh everything's closed
everything's closed
everything is so it it's i just don't
know like
what's gonna happen yeah even even the
the stimulus check they're only now
i think they want to give it to people
that make under forty thousand dollars
so a lot of people are shout outs i had
read that they they didn't want to do it
because they're
they were getting nervous that people
are just going to choose not to go back
to work
on purpose well there's nothing open
exactly so
that was the case before all the
shutdowns yeah and then
today yeah yeah so who knows what's
going to happen
because they have they can't just leave
people out in the cold because you
cannot you have to extend this out
exactly even if it's not 600 has to be
something yeah yeah
it has to be something but no like like
i knew like i just told you guys this
before
before we knew that gyms were shutting
down i was like yeah i'm gonna have to
stop playing as much because i know
life's gonna get back to normal and i
can't i'm not gonna be able to play for
six hours a day when i have my normal
schedule and i know that
uh but yeah they just [__] shut
everything down today out of nowhere too
i heard that this press conference that
the governor had or whatever was
supposed to be on friday
and i heard nothing and now all of a
sudden monday oh well the government's
shut down now so you could keep playing
your damn games and
every day i hear this new statistic that
like us has broken another record
for cases of coronavirus it's like [__]
dude like we're we're
at the end of the day we probably
shouldn't have opened up everything as
soon as yeah that's the thing that
that's what we were talking about that
when the first reopening was happening i
was like dude this is gonna happen a
little too soon i mean i felt like
the things that were way too soon i feel
like the restaurants were fine as long
as it was like covering and you had a
lot of outdoor seating i thought that
was okay but beaches
public parks yeah all that [__] yeah
that's a no-go yeah bars
yeah yeah the fact that bars and clubs
were the [__] weird thing i
you know i actually didn't know that
bars and clubs were open they said the
first weekend
500 000 people were out yeah to go to
bars
like i had no idea that bars and clubs
were open until they shut it down again
yeah i was like wait these were open
why the [__] are bars and clubs open
it's crazy because i have a lot of
friends in arizona like on facebook and
[__]
and some on instagram now like just
seeing them post you know we're over
here all
locked down and [__] like that seeing a
post at [__] clubs and out and doing
all this [__] i'm like bruh
it's like there's a virus going around
killing people
and you guys are just out like [__] it
whatever like remember my damn
when they reopened and then the first
video that surfaced that people were
getting really upset about was like the
ozarks and like the beach clubs and
like all the stuff that's going on and
it's like yeah that was a [__]
terrible idea yeah like people are in
such a rush to get back to normal when
things
can't really be that normal right now
yeah you know and everyone's like in
favor of the
the reopening yeah and it sucks because
i understand the business side right
yeah
of course because people those are close
yeah but people
are close to me family owned one of the
businesses that are affected by this
especially
today shutdown right they they own one
of those businesses so it's like
i feel for them because they lose money
when this happens right and they can't
it
them to get those like [__] relief
from the city or to the government
whatever
was [__] impossible so it's like i
understand
in that sense it's like yeah for them to
have their gym shut down
the first time for three months [__]
sucked and then
they open back up so it's like oh cool
[__] finally we're able to open back
up
people are signing up again yeah and
then then they hit him with oh you
people working out have to wear a mask
and they have to wear gloves right
and that already started issues because
people trying to get people to follow
[__] rules is possible and nearly
impossible
and usually this is what i was saying
the same people that are [__] making
it difficult
are the same people that were
complaining that the gym was closed yep
now look what the [__] happened again
exactly right so it's like
it's if i feel it on that sense but also
i feel like yeah
we probably opened up to do your part
and none of this would be happening but
it is what it is a lot of people that
aren't doing their part
yeah well guys this wraps up this
episode of alex's addiction
and uh you could check out alex on lyft
god
uh he will not be going back to work
because the whole world is shut down so
check him out uh you can see him
twitching and you can see nick
twitching at nick the ear he just
started he's over here trying to
talk like he ain't doing nothing but his
full twitch
i just do it like once every five days
or so
nick the ear and lift god everybody uh
we will catch y'all next time i never
thought that i would ever do a podcast
about gaming in my [__] life he's
gonna kill himself
he's gonna game too bro just keep your
eye
on his twitch or my twitch this is about
to be playing lowest listen podcast
that's about to be your highest you're
gonna have to delete this podcast
100 phone ever again bro you don't even
have that many wins in worlds we'll see
y'all next time peace
but